95% de la population mondiale vit sur ce
monde 10% de la surface terrestre
autrement dit la quasi-totalité de la
population mondiale vit dans une toute
petite partie de notre cher planète mais
alors que trouve-t-on dans les 90%
restants et bien ce que l'on va voir
aujourd'hui c'est que une partie du
globe renferme des histoires uniques
avec d'un côté des territoires
magnifiques menacés par la pollution
humaine et de l'autre côté des îles
discrètes peuplées de quelques dizaines
d'habitants où il est strictement
interdit d'entrer alors tenez vous prêt
aujourd'hui on voyage et je vais donc
vous présenter certains des points les
plus inaccessibles du monde une vidéo
qui sort un petit peu de l'ordinaire et
de ce qu'on a l'habitude de faire ces
derniers jours sur la chaîne vous me
direz dans les commentaires ce que vous
en pensez et si vous avez justement
prévu de partir en voyage et que vous
souhaitez réviser votre anglais et bien
je suis très content de pouvoir vous
parler de Camby qui est une plateforme
de cours d'anglais en ligne qui nous
soutient donc en étant partenaire
aujourd'hui alors j'ai la chance de déjà
parler anglais mais j'avais pu tester
pour pour vous en cours particulier et
je trouve ça vraiment top parce que en
fait si vous mettez en relation avec des
tuteurs dont l'anglais et la langue
maternelle ce qui est vraiment utile
pour vous habituer aux différents
accents et en plus c'est hyper flexible
car vous avez des tuteurs qui sont
disponibles tous les jours et 24 heures
sur 24 et vous pouvez choisir donc vos
cours selon vos objectifs aussi bien
professionnels que personnel par exemple
donc pour un voyage il propose
maintenant des cours en groupe que j'ai
là aussi pu tester vous pouvez donc
choisir la thématique pour parler par
exemple de cinéma de sport ou encore
évidemment d'actualité et l'avantage
c'est que vous pouvez rencontrer des
personnes du monde entier et découvrir
d'autres cultures directement via ses
cours en groupe moi par exemple je me
suis retrouvé dans un cours avec
notamment une Brésilienne qui était
présente ce qui était du coup
intéressant parce qu'au-delà du cours il
y avait un échange culturel entre des
personnes du monde entier alors je me ça
vous intéresse je vous mets un lien
juste ici et en description un lien qui
vous offre 55% de réduction sur
l'abonnement de 12 mois pour les cours
particuliers et ceux en groupe mais
aussi un cours gratuit de 15 minutes le
lien est donc directement en description
[Musique]
allez c'est parti et on commence avec
l'île de Tristan da kuna Lille habitée
la plus isolée au monde située en plein
milieu de l'océan Atlantique bon déjà
petit point historique assez intéressant
c'est une île qui a été découverte en
1506 par le Portugais Tristao Hakuna et
elle est restée inhabitée pendant les
trois siècles suivants et là ensuite été
occupée par la marine britannique la
marine britannique en fait était
inquiète que cette île soit utilisée par
les Français comme base stratégique pour
aller libérer Napoléon 1er et oui en
effet Napoléon avait été envoyé en exil
par les Anglais après sa défaite
militaire pas très loin il a été exilé
sur l'île de Sainte-Hélène et puis même
l'île de Sainte-Hélène je dis qu'elle
est pas très loin mais elle est quand
même située après de 2000 km de là bref
vous l'aurez compris l'île Tristan
lakuna est vraiment isolé très
concrètement pour y accéder il y a pas
d'aéroport sur l'île donc pour s'y
rendre en fait faut prendre un bateau
depuis la ville du Cap en Afrique du Sud
pendant environ 6 jours vous comprenez
donc que c'est déjà assez galère mais ça
ne s'arrête pas là puisque les bateaux
qui arrivent sur l'île ne pas se que 8 à
9 fois par an donc moins d'une fois par
mois ce qui laisse clairement pas
beaucoup d'occasions d'y aller mais vous
souhaitez vous y rendre un jour alors je
vous le disais malgré tout ça c'est une
île qui reste habité aujourd'hui il y a
environ 250 habitants et ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est de voir que ce
ne sont ni des scientifiques ni des
militaires comme on pourrait l'imaginer
éventuellement sur des zones comme ça
mais c'est tout simplement des citoyens
britanniques qui ont décidé de vivre
volontairement sur ce territoire le plus
isolé au monde et parmi les habitants
heureusement il y a quand même un
docteur c'est quand même pratique en cas
de besoin et Tristan Bakugan est
approvisionné donc que par bateau tous
les 60 jours ce qui oblige donc les
supermarchés à passer des commandes des
moins en avance et autrement sur l'île
on retrouve tout de même une école deux
églises ou encore un cyber café
[Musique]
allez on passe maintenant à une autre
île ou plutôt d'ailleurs un archipel
français et oui ce sont les îles
Kerguelen surnommées d'ailleurs parfois
les îles de la désolation oui ça vous
plante vraiment le décor ça donne
vraiment envie elles sont situées en
l'occurrence dans l'océan Indien et la
terre habitait la plus proche se situe
après de 3300 km de la il s'agit de
Madagascar alors depuis les années 50
l'île principale des îles Kerguelen qui
s'appelle la Grande Terre accueille une
base française et entre 50 et 100
techniciens et scientifiques ils vivent
alors il y a pas d'aéroport donc pour
s'y rendre pareil il faut prendre un
bateau et c'est là d'ailleurs que ça se
complique puisque il y a qu'une seule
compagnie de bateaux qui peut s'y rendre
et c'est au départ de l'île de la
Réunion et de la même façon que pour
l'île Tristan bakugna les bateaux ne s'y
rendre que quatre fois par an donc
grosso modo une fois tous les trois mois
et ensuite le voyage en bateau dure là
aussi environ 6 jours bref là aussi très
difficile d'accès mais vous l'aurez
compris c'est une île un petit peu
différente puisqu'il y a surtout une
base scientifique et pour l'anecdote on
en a pas mal entendu parler en France
pendant la campagne présidentielle vous
l'aviez peut-être vu lorsque j'avais
interviewé le candidat de Debout la
France Nicolas Dupont-Aignan c'est une
ville qui vous parle en architectes qui
vous parle qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
installer dessus je mettrai les
islamistes condamnés pour terrorisme
voilà ils iront faire un petit séjour
là-bas alors fera du bien en effet
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan souhaite dans son
programme envoyer des djihadistes
condamnés pour théorisme directement sur
les îles Kerguelen pour que ça devienne
en quelque sorte une sorte de bagne
allez place maintenant à l'île de Nord
sentinelle une île qui est
géographiquement plutôt accessible quand
on le voit comme ça sur une carte parce
que les pas très loin notamment de
l'Inde mais le problème c'est que vous
risquez tout simplement de mourir en
arrivant sur place bon déjà dans son
tunnel pour la présenter c'est une île
d'à peu près 72 km², donc c'est
l'équivalent par exemple de la taille de
l'île de Ré et si c'est une île qui est
située au large de la Birmanie en Asie
du Sud c'est un territoire qui est
officiellement administré par l'Inde
mais qui est totalement coupé du reste
du monde à tel point d'ailleurs que
personne ne peut vraiment y accéder sans
se faire tuer bon vraiment j'exagère pas
en disant ça en fait c'est une île qui
est habitée depuis des millénaires par
les sentinelles les sentinelles c'est un
peuple autochtone qui ne laisse personne
approcher son île ils sont aujourd'hui
l'un des derniers peuples à être aussi
éloigné du reste de la civilisation et
on ne sait pas combien d'ailleurs il y a
de sentinelles exactement puisque vous
l'aurez compris c'est dur de s'approcher
mais il y aurait entre 40 et 400
individus qui vivent de la chasse et de
la pêche sur place entre 40 et 400 on
dirait des chiffres des syndicats et de
la police sur une manifestation ça
prouve donc qu'on a du mal à mesurer
tout ça en fait pour dire les choses
leur mode de vie n'a pas vraiment évolué
depuis l'époque à laquelle ils sont
arrivés à savoir il y a environ 50 000
ans alors vous l'imaginez une
civilisation comme celle-ci attire et
plusieurs curieux d'ailleurs ont déjà
tenté de rentrer en contact avec eux ça
a été par exemple le cas d'un touriste
John show un touriste américain qui
s'est rendu sur l'île en novembre 2018
pour essayer d'évangéliser les
sentinelles en vain puisqu'il a été tué
et parmi les rares personnes revenus
vivantes de leur expédition sur Nord
sentinelle il y a notamment
l'anthropologue indien trilocnath pondit
qui a eu un contact avec les sentinelles
il a débarqué en 1991 avec des outils de
quoi cuisiner ou autre accompagner de
son équipe peu après cette expédition le
gouvernement indien a décidé d'interdire
l'accès à l'île et en 2013 d'ailleurs un
cordon de sécurité entoure en Lille sur
plusieurs kilomètres a été mise en place
dans la mer l'objectif est très clair
évitez que les bateaux s'y approchent et
éviter que certains touristes ou
explorateurs tentent d'approcher la zone
[Musique]
allez on poursuit avec la ville de la
Rinconada dans la région de pudo au
Pérou en Amérique du Sud il s'agit de la
ville la plus haute du monde rien que ça
elle est située après de 5300 mètres
d'altitude dans la chaîne de montagne de
la Cordillère des Andes niché entre
plusieurs glaciers et à titre de
comparaison le Mont Blanc qui est le
plus haut sommet d'Europe et situé à
4800 mètres d'altitude et l'Everest est
situé à près de 8800 mètres alors
environ 50000 personnes habitent à la
rinconnada il travaille en grande
majorité dans la même mine d'or et il ne
quitte presque jamais leur ville et pour
cause la seule route qui permet
d'atteindre cette ville elle passe par
des zones montagneuses où il est très
compliqué de circuler il y avait
d'ailleurs couverte de glace la plupart
de l'année et en plus d'être un lieu
difficilement accessible les conditions
de vie à la réconada sont déjà très durs
d'un point de vue biologique par exemple
puisqu'on est en haute altitude il y a
environ deux fois moins d'oxygène qu'au
niveau de la mer qui peut être un défi
majeur pour ceux qui ne sont pas
habitués à une telle altitude il y a
également très peu de végétations un
réseau électrique vétuste ou encore par
réellement d'eau courante selon les
scientifiques qui ont étudié cette ville
Ringo nada est une anomalie et leurs
travaux montrent d'ailleurs que ses
habitants sont à la limite de ce que
peut tolérer physiquement un être humain
on va maintenant parler non pas d'un
lieu mais d'un ensemble de lieux
peut-être l'un de mes préférés dans
cette vidéo aujourd'hui c'est les TP
puis les TP puis en fait c'est ces
montagnes au sommet plat qui s'élève au
dessus de la jungle tropicale il se
trouve dans le plateau des Guyanes en
Amérique du Sud et notamment au
Venezuela alors autant vous le dire tout
de suite là on rentre dans la catégorie
des lieux complètement inhabités si je
vous en parle donc c'est déjà parce que
c'est très beau alors personnellement ça
me fait penser à les paysages qu'on
pourrait voir par exemple dans Avatar
mais surtout ce qui est intéressant à
voir c'est que en raison de le
raisonnement les thés puis accueillent
de nombreuses espèces endémiques
autrement dit des espèces qu'on ne peut
pas trouver ailleurs par exemple un
tiers des espèces qui vivent dans les TP
puis de la Guyane vénézuélienne n'existe
nulle part ailleurs dans le monde mais
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont aussi
inaccessibles bon vous le voyez
visuellement donc je vais pas vous faire
un dessin mais en fait ils ont des
flancs verticaux qui tombent quasiment à
pic et les plus grands et puis mesure
plus de 3000 mètres de haut ce qui fait
qu'il est très difficile forcément
de s'y rendre à pied il y a seulement
trois de ces montagnes qui peuvent être
explorées à pied autrement faut s'y
rendre donc en hélicoptère
enfin dernier lieu inaccessible et pour
le coup on peut vraiment dire qu'il est
puisque personne vraiment personne n'a
jamais réussi à s'y rendre il s'agit du
Mont gankar pusum un sommet de 7500
mètres d'altitude situé à la frontière
entre le bouton un pays de l'Est de
l'Himalaya et la Chine et si on en parle
aujourd'hui comme l'un des lieux les
plus inaccessibles du monde c'est parce
que et bien cette montagne est
considérée comme le plus haut sommet du
monde n'ayant jamais été gravis en effet
il y a eu quatre expéditions au total
entre 1985 et 1986 mais personne n'a
réussi son ascension bon et en plus
aujourd'hui il y a vraiment aucun moyen
d'y accéder puisque l'accès à cette
montagne est interdit en effet d'après
la BBC depuis 1994 l'ascension de tous
les sommets de plus de 6000 mètres
d'altitude du pays n'est pas autorisé
pour des raisons religieuses bon et
c'est aussi pour des raisons de sécurité
dans ce cas précis puisque en cas
d'accident et bien ce serait très
compliqué justement de porter assistance
aux personnes en danger
bref voilà donc pour cette vidéo qui
sort un petit peu du cadre traditionnel
de ce qu'on fait sur cette chaîne je
mets ça vous a plu pour nous soutenir
vous pouvez vous abonner on tente
quelque chose de différent je suis aussi
preneur du coup de vos retours
directement dans les commentaires ça
vient en complément en tout cas aux
autres vidéos que vous pouvez découvrir
sur la chaîne prenez soin de vous
présenter nos proches et puis je vous
dis à très vite